a debate in the European Parliament on
the humanitarian situation in Gaza back
from a trip to the Middle East the eu's
foreign policy Chief yose Burell
addressed divisions in the
block we ought to be able to defend the
Palestinians rights to have a state
without being categorized as
anti-semitic and it ought to be possible
to criticize the policies of Israel
Israel's war on Gaza has split member
states the eu's top institutions and
left the block floundering to project a
uned united front there have been mixed
messaging and diplomatic gaffs and
although the EU agrees on condemning the
attack by Hamas on October the 7th it
has failed to agree on a response to
subsequent Israeli attacks that have
killed thousands of Palestinians
including
children on one hand the countries
including Germany Austria and the Czech
Republic that support Israel's response
on the other countries including
Luxembourg Ireland Spain and Belgium
who've criticized it as
disproportionate taking matters into
their own hands the leaders of Belgium
and Spain are on a joint peace mission
to the Middle East Spain and Belgium
have taken the initiative now to to
visit the region uh because there are
countries in Europe that want to play an
important role to bring peace in the
region and uh I think we have a role to
play Belgian MPS are also considering
possible sanctions on Israel we have to
consider a travel ban uh against uh
Israeli settlers but also against uh
responsibles in Israel in the Army in
politics the responsibles for those
atrocities and for those attacks against
against civilians in in in in Gaza in
recent weeks the eu's been more vocal
about the suffering in Gaza and
increased aid for Palestinians but this
rights campaigner says it also needs to
call out war crimes committed by all
sides it's time for the you to stop
saying that Israel needs to respect
International material law and to ask
Israel to stop VI violating
international law United on Russia's
invasion of Ukraine for nearly two years
the eu's inability to uphold some of its
principles and speak with one voice on
Israel's war on Gaza has damaged its
foreign policy credentials and
diminished its influence in the Middle
East and possibly Beyond Natasha Butler
Al jazer
Brussels make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer